gang we're having a heck of a time out
there on that state trashy tour come out
and see the boys little stand-up comedy
plus we play ayg with the crowd it's a
fun fun time yeah we got a bunch of
cities first up we're going to Phoenix
uh Denver second show out of there then
we're going to Salt Lake City Los
Angeles San Diego second show added
there then we're taking it back East
Washington D.C Pittsburgh Buffalo
Toronto second show added there then
we're going to Pontiac Michigan Chicago
Illinois third show added there then
we're going to Minneapolis Minnesota
Madison Wisconsin Milwaukee Wisconsin
Sacramento San Francisco San Jose and
then wrapping it up in Philly around
Christmas time baby get those tickets
we'll see you there welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find that it's
a group to be classy into just a big old
piece of trash I'm your host Dave
trolley coming at you on a beautiful day
we're out back here with hoodies in the
new edition she's down in the basement
pumping a little iron okay yeah she got
the incline bench the Bowflex the whole
nine yards you really get it to get it
on there all right hell of a grip on
that broad okay Mike hose is coming at
you from right next to me I'm confused
she's down there she's down in the
basement where are we we're in the
auditions out back baby I forgot which
way I came in I apologize you see the
goddamn screen door there Diane looking
at the neighbors over there so why is
this so much humidity and milk Dude down
here we had that at it
keeping the wheel going baby put a
humidifier in don't forget where you
came from Daddy humidifier with a piece
of bread in there
spores going my co-host is coming at you
from right next to me he's the salt in
the summer baby give it up for KJ Kevin
James Ryan a lot of tank thanks for
tuning in that's always a kid well as
always please make sure your rate if you
subscribe on iTunes full video available
on YouTube as you know those numbers are
true
and obviously the greatest website of
all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage check it
out gang it's a [__] party over there
yes it is having a nice quick shout out
to our producer extraordinaire the old
magic man there Toby T-Bone McMullen hey
what's up boys what a pal dude I love
you honest so much he's a guy who's
never walked into a room without a gripe
ready
[Laughter]
I'm loaded locked in low
blanks hollow points this guy's just up
in a country thinking [__] just
letting the mind go yeah shots you know
that's the problem yeah you just nailed
the problem you're just up there I'm not
used to the to the congestion down here
so when you're up in the country you
know yeah you sit around you you then
you start tapping the rifle against the
floor
your mind's got too much time I know and
then you come down here you encounter
just a little bit
you're reaching for the nine millimeter
on the seat you start you start drawing
up plants yeah sure yeah you gotta you
gotta you know you have to stalk out
what you're gonna do first yeah you got
to make your moves Daddy I'm not a
rampage type of guy
I'm looking for uh you're more from the
bell tower I'm more of a murder one guy
I thought it out this is plans
methodical they're gonna look through my
uh computer they're gonna find stuff
they're gonna find weeks and weeks of
plants premeditated Papas yeah he's got
men's Ray over here I'm gonna have Maps
out with highlighted areas because I got
a lot of time on my hands out there in
the country okay thanks to the
Mother-in-law sure yeah mother-in-law
takes good care of you of the two kids
so that gives me plenty of time to sit
around think about how I might blow [__]
off Stir It Up man let's get this guy a
hobby I bet you every every school
shooter pick up golf or something dude
had a mother-in-law had somebody take
care of the baby taking care of the
essentials yeah
yeah yeah gang we could be more excited
to have our incredibly special guests
back with us again today he is [__]
family at this point wanted to have him
over to the [__] New Edition check to
join out a little bit uh he's the host
of The Honest Papa sour he has an
amazing special on YouTube right now
that's creeping on a million get it
there gang and here's the big news he's
gonna beat the Paramount Theater in Long
Island August 17th do yourself a favor
grab some tickets because the word on
the street out there is it's almost gone
it's almost gone yeah give it a pretty
honest Papas everybody
good to see you boys jammed up on the
coming huh guy comes in an hour late
yeah and with he's hit me with problem
after problem his keys his phone his car
parking there's nothing worse than being
late when you could have not been late
yeah sure I did that yesterday yeah I
like to save those for when I'm really
late but when I should have been here on
time but I got jammed up because of an
unexpected faux pas uh-huh
I also think you got out of the house a
little late cause I got a text what's
the new address
and the address was right above the text
you sent me I'm like he's if he's just
getting in the car now this is bad I saw
that I couldn't remember where the where
to these old it's basement was the base
the base she's downstairs same address
yeah so I was like is that the same
address where it was before but you guys
were a little farther up in Philly yeah
yeah or wherever yeah yeah Cherry Hill
there's Pizza South Jersey
it wrong but not too the problem was I
was coming from Long Island because I'm
at the in-laws so I don't think I
planned that traffic Connie's doing
sleep away camp but I actually got here
112. so it was only 12 minutes late I
pulled it right into a underground
parking facility and that's the worst
part when you have a Tesla and you don't
have the backup key you pull it all the
way down and under there's cars behind
you and then you're like oh God I didn't
I because you need to have the spare key
in order to give because I didn't know
this he didn't think about this musk
you're doing he's doing too much he's
doing too much this is something he's
got to add on it's day I forgot my spare
key I need to park my car because I'm
running late for a podcast
software update you think they're ever
in a rocket like who's got the keys
I left despair at the house I had my
phone okay using her iPhone to turn it
on what the [__] so then it becomes this
funny thing where you're like here I'll
leave my phone and they're like no no
they don't want the phone
like it's plutonium
I'm like look I trust you what are you
gonna do you work at the you're not
gonna it's locked you're not gonna look
through it take the phone and they're
like no and then they got to speak to
the managers that I'm waiting for the
manager then the manager comes out he
has the same reactions
so that I'm like how do I get out of
here now sure yeah you're because you're
backed in there as you would call it
jammed up kids are jammed up Jam [__]
up they abandoned you two down there
when you're not giving them the business
they don't give a [__] they could care
less figure it out they just go yeah you
know like you gotta go and so then you
gotta like you know I gotta do like 100
turns to try to turn around and and go
the way I came in where there's all
these cars coming in Yanni's having a
day I'm having a day and I just came
down off of five milligrams Alexa Pro
today is the day it kicks in where
there's no more nothing it's out of the
system it's out of the system oh God
he's raw dogging us right now five
milligrams is nothing though it's like
what's the point you know okay either do
20. I don't know it seems like there is
a point I guess there is but it's like I
didn't feel anything so I said to that I
was like I don't know he was like yeah
you could just whenever they say you
don't have to taper off it's not enough
because usually you gotta step it down
you got a wean you got a wean it's the
smallest so he's like he's just like
cold turkey yeah yeah you got a wean you
know what's working if you got a ween
yeah yeah what are you doing out in uh
on Long Island you got your new baby we
got the new baby so you go out there and
post up for the couple months how does
that work no not a couple months that uh
but for a week I think if it was up to
my uh wife and my in-laws it would be a
couple months okay they want us out
there on the island yeah people from the
island don't want you leaving the island
out there no they don't like that at all
they don't like that they you know we we
live what
an hour 15 minutes away and they treat
it my in-laws treat it like we live in
Denver like they're like they live up
there and they're in Canada I thought
she went up there and and and stayed up
there with you guys I thought that's
kind of how this system works yeah we
she's up there with us but she's she's
nervous she's from she's off of Long
Island my mother-in-law's nervous she
doesn't know what kind of Democrats
could bite her you know
they do not like MS-13 especially Long
Island they're paranoid of MS-13 I
really feel like
we should get together as podcasts and
market like maybe an MS-13 spray okay
like a bear spray yeah I think we could
convince Long Island people to buy or
just go in on it just spray it outside
your house just spray the perimeter to
every every 24 hours it just keeps
Democrats gangs liberals away
everybody's out I know there's like a
bug zapper in the front yard
how are the accommodations out there you
got a guest room I personally they got a
nice spread dude it's nice they live out
there they got like a big house you're
not in like your girl's old room like
from high school no we are yeah we are
is it decorated like that no but she
could know because she's like her dad's
in sync posters and [__] like that no
she yeah but for a while she still had
her College her College grade collage up
you know the college the Suburban a
couple of Lookers on that probably for
sure shout out to spring break
you know she it's a sorority collage I
know I'm very familiar with those are
all right yeah yeah those are nice good
looking girls always had the same room
they got the same room it was always
awesome and there's always a family
collage and then there's a couple of who
is collage yeah yeah always there I feel
like they always had the down comforters
before anybody else
always had that nice down comforter the
room smelled good yeah the best yeah
yeah and a kind of an ornate bed like
overly ornation yeah you know that's a
very I think Long Island like my wife is
half Italian half Greek but she grew up
around Jews so she she's jewified she's
like you're in Long Island it's just
you're it's out there it's gets on you
you know you she might she had a sweet
16. like if you're a dad and you have a
girl in Long Island I I would imagine it
feels similar to being a Spartan dad
back in the day okay and having a girl
you're like oh you kind of want to Chuck
it into a river and try again because
you know it's a liability you know well
you're on the hook for a sweet 16 sure
uh a uh a 50 000 wedding uh a bot
Mitzvah probably sure and a nose job
oh
to pay for sure you're 300K in the hole
as soon as you see the [__] vagina
uh-huh I grew up with a lot of Jewel I
grew up in a lot of Jewish girls and at
some point they always had like a
deviated septum or something and while
they were in there yeah they would do a
little you know that's how they lied
about it yeah
which I'm with do it 100 yeah while
you're in there they it's sort of a
while you're in there operation like I
had the deviated septum so while they
were in there they you know they they
straightened them out yeah they took off
half of this beak yeah we talked about
it all the time we uh we love about
Mitzvah and a bar mitzvah they were
always the [__] best it's like a
[__] wedding man it was [__]
family yeah it's a wedding for 13 year
olds yeah
open bar a DJ let's go it really is sort
of like it feels like it feels like an
adult event for 13 years
everybody's in like bad suits and [__]
yeah yeah yeah yeah everyone's drinking
alcohol yeah I've been to so many like I
know the beginning of the Baruch
yeah there you go I'm not a Jew yeah
yeah that's how you get the good bagels
by the way that goes in Long Island on
point oh sure Point that's why those
people you know don't want to leave
there that's why they they're scared of
everybody else because uh they have
everything there they have it's
self-contained safe great food Comfort
cul-de-sacs are they anywhere near the
beach or no they got beaches out there
South Shore not sure sure they go north
you go to South I don't know North to
The Hamptons there sure they got it's
everything's there do you guys have a
favorite spot you'll go to as a family
yeah
Pizza down there well Timmy D's a big
proponent of some of the best foods on
Long Island it's true and yeah yeah he's
he's a nobody samples like he does
he knows what he's talking about yeah
he's a [__] Master yeah you got I
think you you and him could have a
[__] ah that would be a war dude it's
my dream going to dinner with Timmy
we've gone out we have lunch with them
we had lunch with them and I've never
seen Foley put his tail between his legs
he sat back and said yes sir Mr Dylan
whatever you want me to have wow he
ought I do the same thing when I go and
eat them I let him order the stuff oh
it's the best yeah it's the best of both
worlds because you feel like you're a
little kid with your uncle or something
yeah he's got the best right because
he's uh he's definitely you could tell
he likes to eat he does love no and he
knows he knows who drew and through and
he knows food and he's got classy that's
the gay part so he's like you got a
little bit of all the way he's got a lot
of Long Island in him he's a Brash man
loves the shared apps the apps for the
table he gets us for the table Yeah but
he wants you to look good he wants you
to eat good yeah he's a gentleman yeah
he's uh he's a Long Island kind of guy
yeah so that's he's got a little element
of criminality in him that's long enough
they're all a little crooked sure he
started as a criminal I mean he was
selling sell mortgages yeah I mean he
would sell it and this place yeah put
his upside down on a mortgage from Jimmy
D
she had to refinance she's jammed
shut up and Timmy D baby
holy [__] so is it chaotic with the new
baby it's chaotic man it is yeah it's
chaotic where are your responsibilities
falling how much I wanna how much are
you hands on I'm I'm off the bench I'm
six man of the year that's why I asked
you how long you're out there with the
in-laws because I would imagine you got
to bring tons of [__] with you dude it's
got to be nuts it's true when you pack
with two kids do they have a crib out
there already like do they have some of
that [__] we've doubled up nice doubled
up nice at first it's like pack the
stroller then you realize you got the
dog you got the stroller you got to take
one or the other because you brought the
dog too the dog's got to come I can't
leave them dogs can't operate on their
own do they have a dog out there too uh
Pastor her dog passed away oh my uh my
mother-in-law's uh dog passed away it's
a great it's it's uh she was uh so my
mother-in-law had one of those mini
um Pomeranians
whatever they're tiny I mean okay tiny
like so small they have have you know
they're like the Joe pescia dogs okay
like you know they're yappers they're
yapped they see they're all Joe Patrick
good with a baseball bat he's got a dude
picking its mouth they have no idea
they're all like Napoleonic complexes
sure because you're not supposed to be
that small humans bred these things
these things got the 99.6 DNA the same
as a wolf and it's rolling around and it
doesn't know it's that small so it was
an annoying dog that would bark and bark
and bark and every time my first baby
would would cry starting to sound like
an inside job if I'm it could have been
this [__] thing wouldn't shut up I
got the baby so here's the good part
[Laughter]
I swear it wasn't me so my mother-in-law
feeds it too much so it was like it
looked like a tech like a swollen dress
and stuff man the dog was fat you got
away with words
so she was she would take it to the vet
the vet would be like hey the heart's
enlarged it's too obese whatever she
would keep feeding it I mean she would
put like a uh like a bowl of tuna in the
the dog's bed and the dog could barely
get up and put his head in the ball and
like eat while it was laying down I've
done that yeah yeah it's all right
watching Sopranos yeah yeah yeah and uh
our next door neighbor uh has a cat
outdoor cat so the outdoor cat the dog
went and followed the outdoor cat and
the outdoor cat
took the eye out [__] yeah and um so we
started putting antibiotics in the
little little girl sting you know and
then she just died just she uh yeah I
woke up in the morning and the
Mother-in-law was like you know frantic
holding the body I knew that I knew that
she had the dog had passed but we went
through the formalities I was like take
it to the vet did you was she were you
doing that you're doing that for her I
thought you meant you saw it the night
before it just didn't say anything I put
I chloroformed it down
no but so you knew and you were like
just keeping up appearances for that's a
good guy that's a good move well she
came out fine he starts CPR come on
where's the shovel at that I'ma stop and
get bagels on the way anybody want
anything comes back what it does into
everything
they did all they could
it's like I got to scale you crazy
little cream cheese on his [__]
we did all we could
foreign
she got the eye so the eye she was like
blind to one eye that we're putting
drops in it we're giving her the
antibiotics for a tiny little dog that's
probably a lot of antibiotic to take
she's already got a swollen heart she's
obese I don't think that I scratch
killed the cat but you know the Lord
Works mysteriously sure didn't help yeah
open the door yeah it opened the door
and uh so that morning it was like five
in the morning she's like I think so
she's breathing heavily I think
something's wrong and then she comes
running back and she's like I think I
think the dog's dead the dog had [__]
all over her [__] [__] all over her and
she's freaking out she's freaking out
I'm like driving I knew the dog was gone
because I could see the dog's tongue
yeah it's gone but you got to go take it
yeah you know go take it so she's taking
the dog
uh and then uh I run back put a shirt on
and then I I get to the vet and she's
not there oh my God she I went to the
wrong vet she might have got lost so I'd
call her up and she's like I'm lost and
I'm like yeah at this point at this yeah
so then yeah at this point you can't
just say
hey we tried let's pull over the side of
the road and find let's Bury Bury it
yeah so what'd you do with the where's
said dog now she had Drive put in I
think on something that was a straight
so it was the same name gotcha I think
she put it in Drive instead of straight
so she just was late so I was there
waiting for her she came with the dog
and then you get there we got there and
they're they're all like you know
getting ready in the morning and they're
like do you want us to resuscitate and I
look there was a pause moment there was
that moment what are we doing well we're
both know like I think she's she's
passed on but you gotta say yes it's
been 45 minutes yeah you're at that
point you're trying to get into heaven
or whatever you just can't I think it
was a social pressure that she had with
me and I had with her it's like we both
know that the little poor dog is dead
sure but we got you know yeah go pump
and stuff three times throw tube in
there even though it's gonna cost me
350.
shut up
and then they put you in there are you
paying a bill on that I tried I tried to
pick it up let's split it I tried I
tried to pick it up I pulled up my card
I was like this this death's on me sure
but she's like it's my dog she put it
down and then they put you in the
bereavement room
um I've never been through this they put
you in the bereavement room at the vet
oh really I didn't know they had one of
those it's a separate room no kids so
it's not the waiting room because I
guess they figured that out like if your
dog's dead they don't want to just throw
you in with your dog my vet in
Washington Heights don't have that
you're in and out oh yeah but also
that's bad for business they don't want
you [__] balling your eyes out in the
lobby that's right go out the back yeah
that's why I think they got the smile on
your face Keep Up Appearance plus they
don't want you just signed the new lease
here what are you doing yeah you know
your dog's dad you see another guy who's
got his dog in for an ear infection sure
it's like you want to be in the dead
room no that makes sense I never thought
of that nice in there real nice in there
I just have a spread they got a lot of
photos
no spread it would have been nice if
they had some [__] carrot sticks
something something charcuterie board
maybe a little hummus something I'm
grieving Little Annie any pasta well
muscles red for the boys you know look
she lived a good life just crunch to
snap into a celery stick
okay what do you know about sheath love
that sheath baby best underwear in the
biz over there sheath you get to tuck
your balls and your wiener in little
separate Pockets I don't have to put
them in my butt crack anymore keep the
hot side hot and the cool side cool baby
you can't stay in the AC all summer gang
you gotta go out there everybody we're
out there we're out there we're sweating
barbecues running to work do yourself a
favor with sheath under where you get a
little Comfort down there it's real nice
and they're dabbling in other products
too oh they got everything cooked yeah
yeah I got t-shirts my wife's got a set
I think I'm running her look at going
after a young gymnast you know
I got a pouch for your dick and your
balls down my wife don't use that one uh
you'll be comfortable no matter what the
weather available and tons of cool
patterns colors sheath helps you fit
cheaps helps you look and feel great
baby I've been saying it for years they
were one of the first sponsors shout out
to Robert Pattinson in the in the
goddamn sheath Department even before
they were sponsors we were trying to get
our hands on a pair oh yeah everybody's
wearing my fancy pants underwear uh
uh she's also has Breezy sports bras and
bikini briefs and boy shorts for the
ladies or for me on a tootsie weekend so
you don't have to suffer this summer uh
go to sheathunderwear.com use code
garbage to get 20 off your first order
plus sheath on sheaths underwears 100
money back guarantee there you go that's
sheathunderwear.com promo code garbage
get sheath underwear support the show
support your balls do it gang okay let's
talk about fume shout out to the good
folks over there fume gang when you're
talking about breaking habits going cold
turkey sucks stinks brain is used to
living one way and changing everything
all at once is a huge shock for the
system if you're trying to change that
hand-to-mouth habit make the transition
easy on yourself with fumes yeah fume is
an Innovative award-nominated device no
electronics no Vapes no harmful
chemicals just all naturally flavored
air yeah it's uh fantastic it's easy
peasy it's kind of it's uh they sent it
to me they first they've been a
supporter for a long time as well yeah
little boom you pop it in there easy
peasy uh like it's the satiation of the
hand the mouth your little fingers are
fidgeting sure it takes care of that it
even comes with adjustable airflow dial
movable Parts magnets for the fidgeting
it's fantastic it's the perfect fix uh
to anxiety that comes up when you're
trying to break a bad habit stopping is
something we all put off because it's
hard it ain't fun but switching a fume
is easy enjoyable and can be fun fuma
served over 100 000 customers and has
thousands of success stories and there's
no reason that can't be you join fume
and accelerating uh Humanities breakup
from destructive Habits by picking up
the journey pack today head to
trifum.com and use the code Garb to save
10 off when you get the journey packed
today gang that's tri-fume
fum.com use code garbage to save an
additional 10 off your order today do it
gang check them out now back to the show
back to the show holy [__] what is this
Ranch nice little spread yeah it's got
some coconut shrimp would have been nice
that's a bummer man I'm sure she wasn't
she was upset she was upset but you know
uh there was this thing where it's like
having to new baby and then this dog was
a lot so it was like sometimes the Lord
just goes Works in a mysterious way I
think that's the way she looked cleared
the plate for you and she's got the new
baby the shower with affection and all
that kind of stuff yeah and so like I
said that dog was in tough shape as it
was and the cat I think the cats uh saw
any bad blood with the neighbors with
the no they were great about it yeah
they feel great about it yeah they were
really great they apologized uh you know
but it wasn't their fault because
because her dog followed the cat looking
for trouble their property kind of
looking for trouble in the cat
kind of was like you know [__] around
find out yeah you got any beef with any
neighbors right now no we're all set
everything everything's good okay that
would that would be tough sure when you
live in a small community if you have
beef that throws the whole thing off
yeah yeah turns into dead wood yeah
that's tough because it's amazing it's
ironic because when you live in the city
you have so many more neighbors yeah but
you don't know any of them no one knows
anybody I mean I before this I lived in
an apartment building I couldn't tell
you one person who lived in my apartment
now I never see anybody yeah anybody no
I have a thing I I like it that way too
uh I'm purchasing a home and a home I'm
going home and uh you tell me you go to
him do you go introduce yourself to the
neighbors or should I wait for them to
come to me that's I uh what did you do
because you're an animal if you're from
you're a Brooklyn piece of trash yeah
yeah yeah
um it was uh it's with me I kept it
organic brings over a half a pizza
I got a couple slices left I got it in
the city kicking [__] out of here it's
coming with a bagel and just cracking it
yeah you got I did it naturally like you
know if like a ball from their dog came
on my lawn we go meet in the middle hey
how are you yeah all right right yeah
yeah keep that [__] mud off yeah
but I feel like every area has one
maniac
because there's a guy who lives adjacent
on a block and like everyone talks about
him and he's like a maniac like if your
dog's on his front lawn he yells a kid
there's always one
why you put cameras on the tree like he
built a thing so he built the thing juts
out from his property to get the angles
he's got all the angles of cars coming
and going coming and going sounds like
my kind of guy
he's gonna wire the [__] trees down
there oh there's gonna be a perimeter
for sure perimeter yeah I got cameras
too yeah you gotta get camera they're
available to get yeah they're the
gateway drug to voting Republicans you
get your first ring camera that's how it
starts you start checking the app you're
like what's the balance all it takes is
one guy trying to steal your Amazon
packages that's it that's it right
across the board let's go yeah you don't
do that no that's let that happen what
you don't go around [__] knocking on
I'm not no well my wife asked me and I
said I don't know I had lived in The
Burbs you know outside Affiliates and
then here now I don't know you know like
you said you don't introduce yourself in
in the in your building people don't
like my cousin they're they're older
when they they just sold their house and
they retired and [__] but I remember
them telling me uh when they were
selling the house just ask them about
the neighbors and stuff he's like when
we moved in
well you know we just moved in we're a
young couple couple of kids we walk over
to the uh to the neighbor because he was
out in his front yard like what you're
saying hey I just want you to know we're
so and so we just moved in and the guy
was like listen I don't want to know you
we I don't want to be involved and just
walked away wow yeah people are weird
like that that's what that would that
would make me feel uncomfortable for the
rest of the time I lived 100 yeah yeah
why you got to keep your eye on that
dude yeah that's the guy that's probably
the one guy in the area right there but
then you know what he said something
happened years later like there was a
fire or something like that that guy
[__] came over and helped him out
Johnny on a spot yeah just didn't want
any any social or not I kind of get it's
like you don't want the I don't want
your business you might be familiarity
breeds contempt yeah but maybe uh hello
you know yeah hey how you doing yeah
just got delivered to my house this is
your water bill sorry I feel like you
could communicate that with energy you
don't have to come out and say it sure
you can just yes you can say hi at the
intro and in the next one just give the
the nod the nod the neighbor don't
engage as much yeah I love the neighbor
now when I'm done out at my mom's
walking the dog everybody drives by a
nice way I don't get the wave I'm
[__] pissed yeah what is that wave
thing that everyone waves lets everybody
know we're all we're you know we're all
right yeah yeah there is a different
vibe and a burbs with that yeah it
really is it's nice dude it's the Last
Stand of America out there it is right
yeah it's [__] all right you look
good by the way have you dropped a few
dropped a couple I can see kids doing
good you look really good thanks yeah a
little bit of it's the shirt the shirts
fits a little if it fits me good job
just buying bigger shirts true classic
baby I got one of those on right now
yeah huge that's my gold again they go
up to 3x I want to get into a true
classic true Classics help you hide
stuff I'm gonna wait about another 20 25
pounds then I'm gonna [__] go out and
get all new [__] now what are you doing
what are you what's your some of the
methods
it works it works he's dropping pounds
yeah I feel I feel nauseous a lot I feel
sick to my stomach
I feel a little weird but yeah it just
took away
um it just like I love to I eat
emotionally right so I love to yeah sit
down Sopranos get the penny all of vodka
get the garlic bread with the cheese
I'll get a beef patty I'll get two Dr
Peppers throw a cannoli on the back end
of that yeah I'm watching soprano yeah
if I saw you preparing that I'd be like
who's who when are they coming over you
are the in-laws stopping by who's
getting married yes I got the Sterno the
big the big train is this uh are you
garbage LLC party yeah yeah what is the
rest it would upset a lot of people if
they saw you know meet me alone in my
devices on my couch in my underwear
hunched over dropping like a little
Penny all vodka on my chest and just
going yeah
yeah that's all gone like wanting to do
that the sad I tried to do it right like
a couple weeks ago and it just wasn't I
just wasn't there I guys fighting modern
medicine yeah was trying to push it his
genetics are saying get fatter and
fatter science is I was about to throw
the case study into a [__] Whirlwind
you know what's interesting I'm so
plugged into you because your energy is
so positive and like big when I walked
in I had a feeling something was up yeah
yeah I gotta say as a guy who spends all
of his time with him he's moving better
babies he's got a little pep in his step
he's back in dungarees
he's normally rolling in in [__]
basketball shorts and Orthopedic [__]
Crocs back on the jeans he's also got a
little deer and headlights kind of look
to him he's in a whole new world right
now yeah you're because like you're not
I think it's a new thing yeah you're in
a new world now it feels good I'm like
where's my appetite this is the thing
yeah that's the weird part I was I was
uh I'm a little bit heavier than I got
to I'm like five pounds away from what I
was last summer when I was working out a
lot and just really trying but now it's
it it feels it's different that that
that that that uh like urge or weakness
is gone that's really what it did it it
like helped me the desire gave me a
fighting chance I think this could just
be in my head but I I think I think it
works man I tell it for sure dude yeah
yeah for sure it's all the rage for a
reason because I don't eat uh all I have
to do is get through one urge when I get
home at night yeah I want to get
something to eat and I'm not hungry
right but I want to get this [__] I want
to get something to eat and if I give
that a minute it goes away then I go to
bed on an empty stomach I wake up hungry
hop on a scale down two three pounds
right it's [__] awesome throw some
eggs on get some water in me now are you
feeling any of the Motions the emotions
that you hide with eating are those
starting to come out or not oh I'm
losing it yeah yeah got a bit of a dude
on it yeah yeah I've been on the other
end yeah yeah a lot of a lot of short
rude text messages the anxiety is
[__] anxiety yeah yeah
it's you know you're gonna it's like
you're gonna keep them alive but then
I'm gonna take my life because he's
crazy I don't know what and I didn't
really think about that until you just
said it yeah that that might be what it
is but yeah I've been [__] oh it's a
hundred percent yeah yeah I was gonna
reach out to you a couple days ago
I like your Greek face you honest two
podcasts ago when you were in here
you bet the ottoman [__] set me up
with that [__] thing
yeah yeah yeah you should reach out
anytime no just it just maybe oh I don't
know if I need you to talk
crazy sandwich
we start doing a pot on the ring cam
yeah welcome back to doorstep the
doorstep but yeah this pops it's an age
Foley
who's your neighbors looking at you
weird
yeah just about
um maybe uh maybe a little a little
medicinal something right you know what
I mean you do therapy uh I was and then
I've been poking around I talked to
somebody through uh through better help
a couple of times yeah
um
[Laughter]
always be closing that's the type of
plug they like straight in the flow no
no you hate my dildo from Adam and Eve
at least I'm sitting on one right now no
no yeah so I reached out to that a
little back and forth with that I do
want to find somebody and I have been
thinking maybe you know five milligrams
of this something of that just to yeah
because I get spurts where it's like oh
[__] that isn't real and I was you know
you were I thought for sure like
something was this was gonna be the
thing and then it's not and you're like
[__] I spent two days [__] obsessing
over this right and somebody I can't
remember who it was it was some movie
star just did a thing where they were
talking about like the you know the
addict's mind that they like normal
people will think of something worry
about it they'll process it and then
they'll move on in the Attic it just
keeps spinning and going around in
circles until you make a move on [__]
you know some booze or whatever you lack
uh yeah the wheel's been going real bad
that's right you need to you need
therapy yeah because there's no
self-reflection of like is this crazy
it's just like this is the truth and
you're like I asked him if it's crazy
but I don't want to be your [__]
therapist you're good no I but you
should be having office no because then
I yell at you and you get mad at me
maybe needed me you get mad at me now
what happens is he yells at you and then
I go and do the same thing to my mom
yeah I I hit my head Patty with a lot of
when him and his mom get together it's
the Bureau of crazy
they got the charts going yeah you got
to get underneath all the way to the
sadness so that takes you gotta you
gotta put the hard hat on you gotta you
gotta dig you gotta get the drill you
got to get under there which isn't there
a shot for that we can do yeah those
epic's got to come out with something
yeah they're [__] doing everything
it's crazy when I went to the
endocrinologist she was like you know
you're gonna want to drink less you're
going to want to smoke less it's good
for your heart it's good for this like
predictions and stuff like that yeah not
great on the liver and kidneys they say
right because just not so much that but
you don't you're not thirsty so you
don't drink enough water to [__] to
keep everything moving that that adds to
it yeah I also think too that you know
the the drug itself yeah but it's just a
hormone yeah but it's probably a good
opportunity now that you're not eating
you don't have an appetite to kind of
peek under the hood take a peek and find
out what it is you're masking with the
eating because you're not eating because
you're hungry it's emotionally I do the
same thing yeah and uh yeah and I have
my like addictions they're not like
substance but like I do things like
obsessing and then you peek under the
hood it's scary to peek under the hood
but eventually you know I've looked you
learn things which are good the hoods
the Hood's ugly the engine is I don't
know who built that engine but
you almost had a [__] real good thing
going here yeah you [__] it all up
yeah that's why I want to do this edmr
you know yeah I want a concert or
something
you're back in your Club in days
Tiësto headline you gotta bring your own
ecstasy and whistle
[__] Sandstone I just stopped to show
up to the therapy session with like
[__] a whistle and do a Molly
yeah didn't hug me she had Alzheimer's I
got shot in 2002.
forget you got shot yeah I don't know
that I know you've done I don't know
that story yeah I got I I took I took
some I just got so there's Trauma from
there I got to deal with that because
the panic attacks started there you know
but I was also doing 911 disaster relief
social work at the same time so that's
when I started really the panic attack
started and this was like the internet
was just started right early 2000s so
you couldn't just Google what is a panic
attack I had no idea what was going on
my first one like 12. yeah didn't know I
thought the world was collapsing we just
we just talked about this yesterday I've
had acid reflux and anxiety since I was
a little kid and didn't know it yeah and
it was [__] when you have that [__]
as a kid you feel you're dying it's nuts
[__] middle-aged nine-year-old
that's [__] hard hard
like an old detective the kid's like you
got candy they [__] candy I need a Pepto
does your mom have a medicine cabinet my
ulcer's acting up it's so funny y'all
this is like I got shot in full it's
like pepperoni really
I
had a similar experience
one day if I have Peppers before 12
o'clock I'm a real gym that's my 911.
that feels like you got shot that
burning
talking about 9 11 and getting shot yeah
yeah you know what you know what a thing
is man my mom had the slow Descent of
Alzheimer's was like 15 years and it was
it was a horror movie it's a nightmare
yeah I talked about it on Ryan Sickler's
podcast sure shout out to sickle and
then like I just got all these messages
um from people who are going through it
and um it's it's just it's a nightmare
it's like a frustrating nightmare like
you can't you're helpless you don't know
what to do it just got my pop he passed
away in September wow yeah how long wow
your dad yeah it was a few years he got
a Lewy body's disease your dad yeah wow
sorry to hear that yeah it's okay yeah
yeah so I'm with you and his Gran his
mom had it yeah his mom had straight old
school Alzheimer's yeah and she would
eventually we tried to keep her in the
house but we had to put her in a nursing
home and this is when I was a little kid
and we'd go out there every Sunday yeah
and I would [__] freak out everything
it's a horrible [__] hated it it's a
horror movie and she didn't know who we
were and she it was a [__] nightmare
it really is like living in a horror
movie yeah you see things and you
experience things and you you deal with
them things emotionally that you you
just don't know what to do with you have
guilt you have sadness you have anger
you have a frustrate you have all these
emotions and you don't know how to
process all of it so uh did your mom
have it straight up the middle like she
didn't know who you were and it just
slowly started going okay no it started
it was worse because it was like a slow
creep so it started with like you know
the same phone call over and over again
leaving the stove on you know go
upstairs I'd come home like pot would be
burning like the bottom of the pot she'd
be boiling eggs or whatever would just
be
smoke everywhere she has no idea you
know it's dangerous yeah she started
donating to the same Charities over and
over and they just pray on and she
forgets so they call back over and over
thousands and thousands of [__]
scumbags I mean it just gets crazy and
then you try to you know she was a proud
woman so you try to move her and she
would you know you have to when we moved
there me and my brother we had to like
drop her off and just leave we had to
trick her and just walk out the whole
thing is I mean you got to put her in a
facility yeah when you put her in the
memory care facility and because
sundowning that night time it gets worse
they call it sundown yeah for some
reason when the Sun goes down they get
more confused yeah so I'd be on stage
and my phone would be buzzing and I'd
get off I knew who it was so I'm like
trying to be funny while this is
knowingly something's happening it's
like a horror it's like I don't know how
I did it right and then I'd get off the
stage and there'd be like 100 messages
from her and it would be the same
message of her panicking telling me I
had to come rescue her she's trapped in
a building and it was just a nightmare
Jesus so now that it's over and now I
have two kids and you have kids it just
it all it's like mine it's all coming up
whoa like I'm dealing now that
everything's okay it's like my mind is
going you have to deal with this now it
didn't let me deal with it then because
then I wouldn't you're in it I wouldn't
have been able to function either so I
think your brain just gives you a
defense mechanism and puts the walls up
goes deal with this well when you get
through it you'll figure it the [__] out
right yeah and so uh yeah you know now
I'm like all right I'm gonna deal with
all this so therapy is good for that you
know it's it's you just gotta do it you
got to get to the bottom of what what
causes the anxiety what causes you to do
obsessive thinking and behavior you know
to cover what and get to the bottom of
it feel it and then [__] move on yeah
write up a Bernie
[__] life I'll stick to the pbr's at
night they shut the old machine down
well the Irish I think Sigma Freud said
right the only group impervious psycho
psychoanalysis give me a six-pack
that'll stop the thoughts I'll get a
good night's sleep wake up put my hard
hat on go to work he was all yacked up
when he said that though he's probably
trying to impress some chick at a barn
yeah the Irish just have that look they
just got that look they go they just
it's like bury it it's like a it's like
a Superman force field or like the Green
Lantern they just put up a [__] car a
booze force field last time I saw him at
the stand like two weeks ago and he's
like
don't look at my girl
you just try to have like uh you're like
how do you feel and it just hits their
force field and bounces off it's not
healthy it's claimed you know it's
claimed a lot of people in my family uh
but it works right anybody in my dad in
my parents generation on my dad's side
of the family uh how's everything going
good everything's good yeah yeah it's
good all right I'm fine fine hit one of
my uncles his nickname was fine
because anytime you ask them he'd be
sitting there like this yeah how you
doing fine yeah it comes in with like a
wound on his head I'm doing all right
fine
shout out to the Irish baby it's a way
to cope I mean if I was the Catholic
Church way to go I would Target the
Irish toe sure if I was gonna do some
bad things they keep their head down
I'll be like these people ain't gonna
say nothing yeah they're happy to be
those parrots are gonna pretend like
nothing's weird man when their kid comes
home with a twitch yeah
that meeting Monday morning when they
first figured that out boys I got a gold
mine for us
I just found a demo that we're gonna do
real well with the O'Briens keep their
mouth shut yeah I can't I can't what
could have happened he spent all night
at father McLaren's house they were
praying it must be something else yeah
they just they just walk around it they
just go where's another route sure yeah
yeah yeah you can stick and move they're
just going alternative route alternative
route
please touch your alternative route give
me a beer alternative route take the
bridge
hey ain't over the pain nothing wrong
with a side road I'll tell you that a
little detour yeah a little access way
go local you'll be all right it's a
couple 15 minutes yeah we sidestepped
that a little bit uh this one priest
like took a shine to my brother when he
was when he was an altar boy and I
remember he took us out to dinner and I
remember that even as a little kid I was
like what's this [__] guys that one
will do anything for chicken tenders
yeah dude he took me my brother and my
mom out to dinner one night and I
remember being in a restaurant like
something's not cool here Dad is and
they put instincts he got he got popped
a couple years later yeah wow you're
that close that close he was uh he was
he was considered he was he was doing
reconnaissance yeah he's checking yeah
he's trying to find out the family yeah
he wanted to see if the family was tied
if they would watch you yeah sort of
like when a hawk circles when you have a
tiny house dog out considering it yeah
just is this wow you got clothes
yeah you escaped yeah or maybe if you
didn't so you kids talk a lot yeah yeah
your parents would you know did they ask
you well what time you're coming home
and who are you dating are they
interested
who are you dating
kids like to drink
so I think serious with Father Tom
what's happening
great so he got popped huh yeah I got
popped a few years later God it's so
it's so everywhere we got pulled my
brother and sister went to uh Catholic
school they're older and then there was
Rumblings of relocation or whatever so
we got pulled out of I never ended up
going to Catholic school when they think
my mom was like yeah we're not [__]
doing this yeah but still
Catholic throw and throw yeah they'll
church every week you were fine don't
worry yeah little I'll go yeah
oh butterface Ryan this one doesn't wipe
well
they still do pretty good I mean you
know like considering the amount
the amount like the sheer amount of
evidence against like how many they've
caught doing it sure Catholic Church's
still doing good you would think at some
point somebody up there would be like
all right we're [__] cracking down on
this yeah they still keep [__]
shifting it keeps shifting and moving
it's crazy what's the what's the angle
there money yeah it's um I know but
wouldn't you wouldn't you make more
money if you were like [__] all right
we're [__] taking care of this I
think you know what it is I you know
what I think you know I think it because
it's so certain because like the
evidence is out because they've admitted
because it's all been caught and there's
all this evidence and they've paid all
this money and retribution and legal
fees or whatever I don't think it has
that juicy conspiracy thing to it people
like to be a part of figuring out what's
going on there's no questions it is what
it is and people go ah the people that
are still part of the church wrap their
head around it how it makes it okay with
them and they go that it's that but it's
not everybody every every institution
has bad problems it is what it is right
focus on the right thing keep it moving
people like to see him I'll see you miss
yeah there's nothing to talk about yeah
you know there's no I'm pretty sure
every conversation I've ever had with
you was ended here
I remember one time being a versus
barbecue we sit down like what's up be
honest how you doing because that
Catholic church or something ain't it I
just can't believe like how nobody it's
just like
to
because they're the church so you go
like what are you gonna do my mom prays
there yeah yeah so even you guys
tightened it up as Catholics yeah
house
yeah why don't you ask him what the
Greeks are up to back in the day yeah
Saints over there let's start the
[__] Crusades up again you're talking
to two nights in a Templar right here no
good it's no good it's no good
I just Mel Gibson did that documentary
though I just feel like going like hey
Mel I think you forgot to mention
because he's Catholic yeah I'm checking
the cellar
Mel they're right behind me
turn around turn around
he's like they're in Hollywood they're
already like yeah yeah but also turn
around
look don't look now but there's one
behind you you're over here talking [__]
on Disney yeah what are you talking
about yeah yeah yeah it's an interesting
thing but uh you know there's no
speculation so that's why people that
makes sense it's not yeah it's nothing
to figure out no sensation yeah people
like to get in there and figure it out
and you know try to theorize what could
be when it just comes out there's no
sexiness yeah it just it is what it is
that makes sense yeah how did we get
here
just take it I remember asking you about
restaurants on Long Island
all of a sudden I'm confessed
you guys run an open Highway like no
let's go this way let's get all jammed
up I want to jam you guys up Johnny
man I start opening up to you talking
about how I [__] dodged them on
senior look at the skin of my teeth they
gotta come up with a nosemite for trauma
that would be great if it takes away
your you know the way it takes away your
appetite just takes away the bad guy
I've always said yeah I've always said
that they should be able to combine
every illegal drug a little Coke little
heroine little this little that and
[__] put it in one pill where there's
no no After Effects yeah that's what we
need yeah well you know what the good
thing is we we do that for people which
is great that makes me feel good about
what we do
you know it makes them feel good they
get endorphins it's nice yeah we do
obviously everybody with shows and
comedians you get the messages of like
you know [__] I've been going through
this for whatever reason family thing
loss just whatever and it does make you
like [__] I you know we have so much fun
calling him fat whatever but then you're
like oh [__] this really does mean a lot
to people and it's cool to be able to
Meanwhile you're up there [__] the
phone's ringing from your mom you're
Diamond
I was walking in a mall the other day I
hope you guys enjoyed it
[__] laying on a track and a train's
gone who's gonna make me laugh
I think it is nice for them too to hear
like hey you know you know you're not
alone no of course yeah I think that's
the I think that's where people you know
really
Get Low I fall into that too where they
think I'm the only one going through
this no of course yeah you're not and
that's why it's nice to hear somebody
talk about and you're like oh I'm not
the only guy who fell I'm not the only
guy who lost the love I'm not the only
guy whose mom had Alzheimer's I'm not
the only guy who likes to emotionally
eat whatever it is no for sure of course
the dementia is a real [__] a real
[__] talk about a jam up real [__] up
yeah you're [__] Jam that's a real
[__] up yeah that was the one thing
that bothered me is that like the you
know the life that my dad lived
everything that he did and all that
stuff and then to know that uh you know
in the end he forgot it all yeah you
know it's [__] pain in the ass and
also you don't know how to mourn the
death because it's also relief that he's
not living that way anymore yeah see I
didn't every other other other people
you know they said that and I'm like Dad
I didn't buy that yeah you know what I
mean I I couldn't accept that what do
you mean I couldn't accept well he's at
peace now right [__] that [__] no I want
him here no I want to be mad
I don't care what you like this
therapists say Let Me Be crazy there is
like a it is a tough thing to handle
though so there is that feeling of like
when they go you're like you have that
feeling of like I don't have to deal
with I don't have to see that anymore I
have to deal with that they don't have
to live in that horror anymore there's
confusing feelings of course that get
you jammed up sure now I'm taking your
word and putting it into a horror movie
yeah that's a fun word but it it um but
the many uses yeah but it's like every
but those are all normal feelings it's
like no of course you gotta you know you
gotta work through them all and
understand that I just started kind of
starting to try to talk about it on
stage and that's it is it was a hard
horror movie Yes horror movies yeah
that's yeah yeah it's good now it's good
to know that you me and you have the
same jam up we're both jammed up the
same way yeah and it's good to joke
about that stuff yeah you gotta joke
about it you know yeah that's just how
we deal with [__] everything it just
makes it better yeah we also have to do
some of the work yeah yeah or do drugs
hey you know welcome to the show they
don't not help yeah I'm just trying to
turn into a nice bit I'm trying to get
three new
I'm kidding yeah no I just it's good to
it's good to talk about that stuff and
you're not alone whoever's going on
really yeah of course of course you know
you got a small penis you're not the
only one you are not you are not the
only one I hate that right now yourself
bro well if you got a big one you're not
alone you're not alone either but I
guarantee you you're a [__] jerk just
and you're not better than me
I think it would just be a nice social
service if Justin Timberlake just came
out and admitted that he's got a micro
penis you think he does he's got to have
one why because he's so good at
everything exactly the universe is
balanced there's got to be a micropy
he's the one that gets you Reynolds gets
me I love him which one Ryan yeah
he's not as good as he's all right
though but he just have you ever thought
about how many things Justin Timberlake
is good at singing dancing acting
dolphin dolphin funny yeah yeah he does
it all scratch golf yeah he does it all
I mean he can play Hoops crude business
man handsome guy the dancing is the one
thing I'm most jealous of when I was a
little fat kid and the kid that could
show up at the bar mitzvah or the
wedding and just [__] have the the
the the the confidence to go out and
[__] make those moves yeah and I'm
sitting there with the other older
uncles drinking a decaf coffee wanting
to be out on the dance floor doing the
worm and my buddy Brad Kramer's out
there [__] popping and locking yeah
that's to being able to dance and to be
pretty cool he had the turnaround of a
career he went from being for a guy in
my age I'm 36 I was like you know 13 or
whatever when he insane came out which
was the corniest of the Corn like they
were cornball right everybody [__]
they were you were a kid when that was
happening yeah but they were the punch
[Laughter]
yeah it's like it smells up my room
I want to throw my phone out when I see
it I think I've actually thrown my phone
into like a pillow hard a few times
going ah no Kevin not I know you know
Susie walked out of the room the
photographer said to his assistant ew
I mean he's just I just [__] see him
just get there now look at him right
there that's before [__] he got
that's before the heaters got all yeah
that's before
he had just started smoking I think I
was bumming him I wasn't buying packs I
was bumming them I mean you were Philly
trash all I know baby
trash I mean [__] smoking a Newport
outside of a Wawa waiting for a guy to
buy me a pack yeah I give him five
because they were like 275 back then you
give him five bucks go hey you can
almost get yourself a whole pack yeah
just let me wet my beat know what I mean
let me get my heaters yeah it's so funny
that's something like uh I don't know
how to articulate it but like now when I
see like my nieces and nephews and
cousins do like Philly kind of things
just when they say like yeah I want to
get a water ice or whatever or like but
you know my knees use your thumb my
niece you get set in my shore house
every 10 seconds my niece for a birthday
party she wanted she wanted Wings in a
hoagie train
from premiums the good stuff private
schools sharpest cutest little kid yeah
we get Hoagie tray yeah I wanted Wings
you see that you're like God damn it is
a trashy accent oh it's the worst yeah
it's the worst
my cousin hit me shout out to Mike the
guy who did the walls here I was down uh
I was down the shore with him we went
out to a bar and they were they have
like this there's this bar shot the
number the number one Tavern has a Tully
nut and they don't know what's in it and
uh they're like 11 bucks or something a
clip you know and you're supposed to do
like one or two it's like a kitschy
thing and he goes yo these are real
pricey
you know what I mean get out of this all
that stuff we go to dinner we come out
and we're sitting there having a smoker
we have like one smoke left and this
couple like was walking by and heard us
talking about cigarettes sure enough she
was [__] like South Jersey trash yeah
she's like don't go buy him over an
eight or want twelve dollars a pack yes
lady
[__] Dirtbag yeah yeah I mean you take
that accident you put it like in Paris
oh it's my mom has it it's tough on you
like talk to your mom and she hits you
with it oh I don't know I love it but
it's the same you know what it reminds
me of when you said the name of that
restaurant that you go with the in-laws
I could see your mother-in-law ordering
probably gets the same thing because we
always say like his mom always gotta get
them my salad chicken I'll get the
chicken fronts all the ants all get the
same thing yeah yeah because that's
that's how they they find one dish in a
restaurant they like and they they love
you oh I don't even get anything else I
always get the francaise yeah well you
know every place that has like a strong
accent like that they're the same person
same different place oh 100 yeah
nobody's like a Rhodes scholar with that
accent you're never gonna find someone
maybe a good contractor yeah good
contract is as far as you can go that's
the height of my family is that it was
like you were a blue collar worker and
you got maybe you started your own shop
yeah yeah that then fizzled out but
those accents don't come with books no
they do come with they come out with
they do it's Angela's Ashes and that's
it
I remember when that got popular
when you're younger a couple of Tom
Hardy's yeah a couple of Tom Hardy books
just Da Vinci Code yeah I'm re I'm
reading the secret right now oh that's
black magic in my house freak the [__]
out Da Vinci Code can kick rocks for
Denise but I'll tell you what they do
come on worship they might they might
not be learning Scholars but they come
with a dynamite [__] bacon egg and
cheese in the morning hell of a [__]
cutlet yeah a nice meatloaf and a
[__] load of laundry that smells like
spring for the next six months and
they're all good people like why not
apparently they're not miss they they
attitude is like everything good is here
and they're not wrong and they're not
wrong and comfortable it's it's made me
doing the show so much like you're
analyzing your your family your
childhood there's something about the
the connection of the people is so real
because like a lot of times they don't
have a lot so the relationships are what
like they all have great personalities
not everybody's very funny it's very
like you're just hanging everybody
everybody was funny everybody
is [__] thing 80th funniest dude yeah
yeah like dude you sit back with my
uncles it's like you're they would
annihilate anybody ah my aunt Colleen
would [__] bury me it's the thing
right because like happiness is The
Company You Keep 100 this Society
country though and like our culture
which it tries to in in uh entice us
into thinking that getting things is
what makes you happy but it's not it's
that that's a consumer mentality and
then you get one thing like I now I'm
I'm sick of it and I want the other
thing but really if you're with the
right company you could be in a [__]
Wawa eating sandwiches and you're in
your good place sure being a Pizza Hut
as long as you're what your your friends
people you love it doesn't matter where
you are as a kid the Christmas parties
were [__] the the the the booze was
on the washer and dryer downstairs yeah
[__] the bar was laid out wait a
second what yeah that's how we did it
you guys to turn though laundry room
into the bar yeah wow put that put down
a nice Christmas
um tablecloth wow [__] you got the
bottles couple of two leaders [__]
the cherries the whole nine yards the
trashiness of that surprised me really
oh yeah baby is that
down there [__] mixing drinks at
[__] eight years old right I would
have a tip cup out trying to trying to
get a couple oh yeah right from the
laundry room Uncle Mike and aunt
Colleen's Christmas party bro your
basement was sort of the uh the Hang
everyone was well there was no no that
that was just the bar the the the
laundry room's about three feet across
right so you [__] go in there you get
your drink and then you go back upstairs
so wait so the bars in the basement it's
a self-serve bar yeah you gotta walk
down get the drink bring it back up why
not put it
where the soirees happen that's why we
did it not a lot of rooms
but that's what made it special you know
we still talk about it to this day yeah
and we still do it you know it's crazy
was it a nice table Club Voice or was it
like it's always a nice tablecloth yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah just that old school
mentality I mean you know if you're
going to dress up the washer and dryer
go all the way do it yeah
I mean you know when you're when you're
at the in-laws who who's doing the
laundry she my mother-in-law does
everything she does she does everything
that's [__] she's amazing when she
comes over to your house she's doing
your stuff too yeah she does my
underwear and I I just you get spoiled
by it and then like you just let her do
it like Tim came over yesterday
um because he's out there on the island
on the island so he came down and uh
wait Tim Dylan's hanging at your in-laws
yeah he came over to the In-laws that's
awesome that's Long Island trash I love
that and then she just whipped up a
Greek salad and some Spanish Copita I
just like talking Long Island when I'm
when I'm sure when I bring it up wait
they have a strong accent she makes her
own spanakopita well she bought it from
the Greek store okay but she heated it
up put it out she had a she had a whole
bunch of desserts desserts are huge in
in my in-laws house okay they put out a
dessert tray it's like you feel like
there's 20 guys coming over like my
wedding there was a dessert room it's it
people still talk about it to this day I
wish I was close to what you guys done I
would have invited you to my little
baklava I mean it was a dessert room
what's the pudding one it was vodka
whatever it's called the uh black is
something it's like it's almost like a
like a fly yeah no not ecmac but that's
awesome though oh you know that yeah
Greek desserts can be good that sounds
like Star Wars
yeah and then it just says like sounds
like uh yeah bad guys in Star Wars Star
Wars Star Wars yeah they gotta they got
a trashy accent out there yeah of course
yeah they do sure they don't leave the
island yeah they don't leave out there
dude my family is my I think my mom's
been in New York four times in her life
yeah and she's from 90 miles it's not
that far if I didn't have if if we if my
family wasn't centered where they are I
would I would have been out on the
island on the island
on the island yeah the Island's tough
because it's across 19 [__] Bridges
getting over there getting over to
Jersey Turnpike from [__] Queens you
want to [__] blow your brain yeah
Long Island stuff I think that's why
they stay in Long Island because that
traffic yeah it acts like another body
of water yeah
I gotta go a question what I can't go
into the city that's the whole thing I
mean my father-in-law I've been with my
wife now nine years I think I've seen my
father-in-law
in Manhattan twice or in nine years and
that was for his niece's wedding he was
he was he was bitching about something
yeah and he was in and out back here
they do not like to leave the comfort of
life I like that yeah I like that yeah
like everything's there yeah you did
there's nothing that you don't
have access to out there but they do yes
they don't leave and then they kind of
they they view reality through the lens
of Fox News sure so don't that they that
is picture Megan Kelly on the wall there
oh no there's a gene Perino judge Jean
Perino book size right there at the
kitchen table she wasn't she named judge
Gina she was a judge in Westchester yeah
I don't even know who that is she's got
her show she's like a popular judge Piro
Piro I think yeah oh yes I remember she
had something to shake a family wait a
minute they got a head shot it's his
sign box
when you walk in it's on the mantle see
it's like a you know it's like dude when
I was on Fox news for my my
father-in-law saw me on Fox News
recently it was like a kid from Boston
playing for the Red Sox yeah they were
like they couldn't believe it you hear
about Yanni they were bragging to all
their friends they were telling everyone
turn it on it's gonna be on Garfield you
know it's like that's big the neighbors
taped it that's like being that's like
huge for Long Island Vietnam news I
don't think I was legit till he saw me
on that show cooked a lot of numbers
they're number one now it's crazy how
crazy is that shout out do you think at
some point
the big neck was like maybe we're doing
something maybe we're doing something
wrong I don't know like a small cable
channel is doing this throw the right
blinker on
exit to the right gang no left exits
you think it comes to the next episode
I'm dressed like Larry the Cable Guy
you know those meetings like and also we
forgot about their rights and
representation and then we have to
represent those people and we also have
to think about the climate and the Sea
and the and the oceans and there's just
one guy in the meeting going
I don't think any of that's working
is there one guy going like maybe we
should just think about the show pivot
yeah maybe we should take the the
commercials are really telling too yeah
it's William Devane telling you to buy
gold and [__] salt guns and that and
you want both of them and those jackets
that have like those tactical jackets
that have a thousand Pockets yeah
they're all right shout out to my
stepdad got one for Christmas and I
should keep an iPad in the side nice
reverse mortgage something you can sink
your teeth together it is crazy we gotta
wrap it up we haven't done any questions
[__] coffee down here uh let's do one
or two what what you got Johnny it's
like family you're catching up you know
what I mean hit us we forget we got
business in hand yeah so um this one's
from tip your mailman
uh it says uh
who has the ayg record for moving back
in with their parents how many times you
ever move back in a lot I can't move
back in a lot yeah what's a lot so free
after college I moved back in okay okay
then I moved finish college finish
college back in with the parents back
into the mom's house then moved out me
and my buddy Jesse moved out we got an
apartment only a couple blocks away then
moved back in with the parents why'd you
do that uh Crash and Burn we were living
in a rent control apartment that my
friend grew up in like a couple blocks
away from where we fixed it up it was
real cheap City caught up to you they
the landlord caught up to us kicked us
out yeah sure it caught up to us so
moved back in but also my mother was
having Alzheimer's so I was helping her
out too a little bit gotcha then I moved
back out went to Miami did the show in
Miami Fusion sure uh you know lived in
Miami for a year oh you were you were at
your parents right before that right
before that yeah you were in the city
you were cooking I was cooking and then
moved to Miami lived in Miami for a year
then came back back into
[Laughter]
don't touch my room I might be back
yeah I think I have after college
uh and then I moved out into a townhouse
that my stepdad on I got kicked out of
there went back to home
and then move down to Philly when we
were living together and then moved back
home right before I came back up here
but that was just a couple of months
that was that was that was a handful of
three you got three I got three on it I
think we're tied that's tied yeah I got
uh
flunked out of college sophomore year
back at the house that summer going to
Community College he's gonna get both
teams ready Johnny
if we're doing this let's do it right
yeah the way that started I'm not
optimistic that we're gonna win then in
uh then theater school for two years
then back at my mom's then North Canton
moved to North Carolina
came back from that I was I I had a
residency residency at the folks place
for a little story already dude that's
three we're not out of the 90s
pre-911. we're at 98 dude you still got
New York up to up to New York with my
brother in 99
uh with him until about 0-6 and then on
my own in Sunnyside Queens nice friend
for two years nice the dark days
um then back to I went a pit stop at my
buddy's house to dry out and clean up
[__] stayed there for a month back to
my mom in a couple of months that's
djokovic's 24th grand slam right there
this beat and then down to Philly with
my boy
and then that was it four not bad you
did do a lot of hopping yeah I was
expecting a higher number that's pretty
good during the pandemic I was down
there like a tick though the first part
of that was like a seminar on how to get
educated but not educated sure he went
to Community College and then theater
school
and talk about going to school without
going to school yeah paperwork
I made a living at it yeah I mean that
kind of cancels each other out yeah but
we gotta wrap it up gang gang uh we love
the Yanni we [__] love you to death
this is funny it's always I'll uh we say
it all the time you're welcome back
anytime it's always family brother
family always good I mean this Edition
is thank you this is classic thank you
yeah yeah Cody did it up nice for you it
smells like new rug and I like that gang
you know him you love them Giannis Papa
sour special out on YouTube [__] get
that over A Millie baby let's go on
August 17th the Paramount Theater out on
the island treat yourself go see Yanni
one of the best in the biz anything else
you want the folks out there to know
that's it just check the Pod uh and uh
my giannispapiscomedy.com for tour dates
like I'm I'm on tour all year so almost
every weekend I'm somewhere check it out
see me and see me in your town go see
him go see on again Kippy what do you
got for him uh are you garbage.com for
all all of our live shows uh shows are
selling out get those tickets please uh
we [__] love you thank you so much
love you gang we'll see you next week